and then I guess this is probably gonna
be one of the last questions I love
really weird history the series you do
you're the only guy no I think that's a
tremendous series yeah
where do you find those stories
generally in history books so you'd like
to really go through it I don't I've
never read those an entry book yeah
no you just read weird oddball history
facts when I was a kid I think I've
hooked up picked up at a book fair at
school weird history facts and stuff and
I read no like no obscure presidential
trivia and things like that I you know
really weird history kind of broke my
heart that was you know I really loved
that series and it was not nearly as
successful as I thought it would be I
plan to do seven episodes simply got
three in and it was just not the amount
of time it took to produce the episodes
now you can do science call sure if you
haven't watched really weird history go
right now share it with your friends I
recommend the America's Emperor or it's
the American improve the America Emperor
of the United States emperor of the
United States incredible operation
mincemeat is my second favorite yeah go
watch it we got to get this thing back
back on track
okay what I mean that was one of my
favorite things that I've made and just
nobody watched it and the people who
watched it didn't seem to I don't know
what happened with it honestly it might
have just been that I was not
advertising it correctly
maybe I didn't you know brand it
correctly whatever that means I have
submitted those as short films to
festivals and so they'll play on a
festival circuit but yeah it was just I
loved making them and I loved the end
result of all of them I liked what we
made I think that maybe if it doesn't
have it have a place on YouTube maybe it
will thrive in some other form or some
other medium the book boy they took a
long time to make those I mean that was
stuff
well the the strange thing about this is
that the one the one analytic you don't
get
YouTube is impact and those videos like
once I saw those I was like oh man I'm a
huge fan I know the fan but I was like
oh this is great content Wow so to me
some sometimes the smaller videos you
can make yeah and it's hard to see as a
creator but from an audience it's
obvious some of the smaller films you do
even though they might not be like
commercially successful you could get
yourself a fan for life you know so I I
are said if I can if if I could if I
could do it I would go back and do more
of those because there are plenty of
stories to tell histories and listen
that way but you know when it's a two
and a half month production cycle I'll
put one of those together we're
animating 100% of it and voicing an
audio mixing and all of that it's just
I've worked I worked more on really
weird history to perfect those videos
than probably any other video that I
made and I loved it because it was a
form of narrative yes that's right
that's what I one of my favorite parts
too
awesome well it's just imagine what I
could do if I had a feature yes yes
there are stories left to tell us you
have to tell us what your features well
I'll say this there are lots of stories
that I'm burning to tell and I've been
very grateful and appreciative that
people have been listening the past few
months last year and a half I hope they
continue to listen I'm going to continue
to try and say things that are worth
hearing
[Music]